right now IVF and surcy have returned to
the news for reasons that we don't have
to get
into this is to me the clearest example
of moral confusion not just in our
culture but even on the right there are
many people on the right many prominent
conservatives who don't understand why
IVF and surrogacy and a market for
couples who otherwise can't have
children like homosexuals to purchase
babies that is wrong they don't quite
understand it there's a guy Richard
hanania who is a I guess you'd call him
a right-wing liberal commentator and
here was his I think sincere confusion
on why conservatives would oppose IVF
and
surrogacy he says let me try to
understand the social conservative
position on reproductive issues abortion
should be banned so poor people can be
forced to give birth IVF and surrogacy
should be banned to to prevent smart and
successful people from reproducing do I
have that
right uh no he does not have that right
the reason that
conservatives oppose abortion and IVF
and surrogacy is because we believe that
people are not property to be purchased
and discarded at
will that's why that's what unites those
two issues that's what unites the
broader sexual ethic among conservatives
what used to what used to inform the
civilization that used to be called
Christendom that is why it's wrong and
it's not just the homosexuals who have
to recognize it you get to in one second
first though when you want to treat your
body right you got to check out good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com use code NES what do
green eggs and your Christmas dinner
have in common they both need a ham to
be complete not just any ham a spiral
cut Heritage pork Masterpiece from good
Ranchers that's the kind of ham that'll
steal the show at your family gathering
and guess what you get it for free with
any good ranchers subscription that's a
whopping $99 value that you get for free
in your first order simply subscribe to
any box you will get your free holiday
ham included in any order get 25 bucks
off every order a free gift in every
third box and free shipping on express
delivery the best part is knowing
exactly where your meat comes from which
is a local American Farm head on over to
goodranchers.com subscribe today with
code nolles kwes to claim your free
Limited stock holiday ham before they
sell out act fast this offer will not
last forever order before December 11th
for guaranteed delivery by Christmas
head to goodranchers.com use code nolles
kwes when you subscribe to get your free
10 pound holiday ham do not settle for
the same old holiday Fair elevate your
Feast with good ranchers this year good
ranchers American meet delivered right
now text nolles to 9898 98 diversify
your savings with physical precious
medals while stockpiling silver in your
home safe with Birch gold group's most
popular special of the year now through
December 22nd for every $5,000 you spend
with Birch gold they will send you a 1o
silver eagle coin for free text nolles K
wle to 98 9898 to claim your eligibility
now you can purchase gold and silver and
have it shipped directly to your home or
have Birch Gold's precious metals
Specialists help you convert an existing
ra or 401K into a tax sheltered Ira in
gold for no money out of pocket they
will send you free silver for every
$5,000 you purchase keep it yourself or
give something with real value as a
stocking stuffer this year just text the
keyword nolles kW to 98 9898 to claim
your eligibility with an A+ rating with
the Better Business Bureau and thousands
of happy customers now is the best time
to buy gold from Birch gold text Noles
kws to 98 9898 claim your eligibility
for free silver on qualifying purchases
before December 22nd that is nolles to
9898 people recoil at
the image of two men creating a
child through
IVF for the express purpose of denying
that child his mother people recoil
naturally some people they consciously
recognize why that is so wrong for some
people it's just a Prejudice and it's a
true Prejudice it's called the wisdom of
repugnance we know it's wrong even if
some people can't articulate
why it's it's harder for conservatives
to understand what the problems with IVF
and surrogacy more broadly so it's so
clear when it's two guys who go out to
look at a catalog and they pick some
woman they they're treating women like
objects like Commodities to be purchased
and they say yeah I want a woman with
blonde hair and I want her to have gone
to Princeton and I want her to work in
banking oh yeah maybe we'll get a Future
Finance here in our family and I want
her to have blue eyes and I want that's
obviously degrading and dehumanizing
then they find some poor woman who wants
to make 20 or 30 grand often in third
world countries or at least in
struggling countries like Ukraine uh
they will say okay I'm going to pick
that woman I'm going to rent her womb
and we're going to implant these babies
uh in her womb and uh then she's going
to gestate our children for nine months
and then we are going to do all of this
with the express purpose of ripping that
child away not only from his biological
mother his genetic mother whom he'll
never know but also from the nearest
thing to a mother he's ever known the
the woman in whose body he has been
whose voice he has heard for nine months
we're just going to rip him away from
that person not give him the comfort of
that person holding him when he's born
and we're going to do that to satisfy
our natural desires but our disordered
Behavior because we have chosen these
two men have chosen to be in a
relationship that is intrinsically
sterile but in order to accommodate
their desires over the needs and best
interests of a child we're going to
create a kid to deny him his mother does
your mother M do you like your mother do
you think your
mother had any positive influence in
your life growing up well you're denying
that obviously we all do we all love our
mothers even if you have a mother who's
not that great you even you still
probably love your
mother you are now depriving your child
of one of the most important connections
that any being can human being can have
that is obviously terribly terribly
wrong and the men who do this a lot of
them probably don't know that and a lot
of them have been blinded to that and
the culture has told all of these men
that it's totally fine and the culture
has told men that men and women are
totally interchangeable and there's no
difference between them and the culture
is the law has even told men that they
have every right to do this so I don't
even blame them all personally generally
they know not what they do but it's
terribly terribly
evil but put the homosexuals aside for a
second they don't deserve to Bear all
the blame for this because the
traditional view is that IVF and
surrogacy are wrong period for everybody
why is that someone wrote to me said
Michael you know I I can't believe you
said this because I I can somewhat
intellectually understand why IVF and
surrogacy might be bad in theory but
I've got nieces who were conceived
through IVF and I'm glad that my nieces
are alive so go f yourself Michael
because I don't anything that would
allow my nieces to be alive live I think
is totally fine you big jerk you Bible
thumping moralizing jerk okay all right
hold on calm down calm down I hear you I
hear
you I'm sure your nieces are
great I'm I'm sure your nieces are
wonderful I say and your niece your
nieces have a right to life and it's
good that your nieces
exist the problem for IVF and surrogacy
is that no ends no matter how good
justify immoral means
no ends no matter how good justify
actions that are intrinsically evil to
achieve them this is the same kind of
logic that we would apply to say rape a
child who is conceived in rape I know
some they have a right to life they're
it's very good that they
exist we like these people had your
nieces God forbid been been conceived in
the case of rape you would you would say
that you would say I love my nieces and
how dare you suggest they shouldn't
exist and dare you say that I'm not
suggesting they shouldn't exist I'm not
suggesting they don't have a right to
life I'm not suggesting they're not good
at all
but let's follow this idea to its
logical
conclusion does the fact that your
niece's existence is good and they have
a right to
life does that fact justify
rape certainly
not
likewise good ends can be wonderful and
we can celebrate them but they don't
justify immoral means the reason
surrogacy and IVF are immoral is because
they they interfere into the family they
break up the the nucleus the very
building block of political Society they
separate the reproductive from the
conjugal
act they establish the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human
life and they can have all sorts of
unintended consequences every six months
it seems there's some story in the news
about how some couples who did IVF
whoopsy Daisy the test tubes got
switched and an Asian couple gave birth
to a black baby so they knew hold on
this isn't our baby and you know the
black couple gave birth to a red-headed
white baby and then this oh whoopsy
Daisy we switched the test tubes around
well now there's a legal case who's my
child that's no good why else what what
else are some of the UN intended
consequences of IVF well uh usually in
IVF many human beings are created
embryos are made and then you use one or
two of them maybe you try to implant
multiple and then oh too many took okay
so we're going to have to abort a couple
of them or you only do one or two at a
time then you put the rest in a freezer
and okay we actually don't want a third
child so then those human beings remain
Frozen on Ice in perpetuity that's
obviously profoundly immoral
what are some of the other problems well
how how do you think you get the sperm
for IVF I listen some of you might not
be as exacting on your views of sexual
morality as say the Catholic church but
uh acts that we would all agree are at
least somewhat shameful you wouldn't go
bragging about them those are involved
in in getting the raw materials and it's
just so damned clinical and it's just so
degrading and
dehumanizing and I cannot stress this
enough it is establishes the domination
of Technology owned by private
Enterprise or the state over the very
origin and Destiny of human life which
is very very
disordered so hard saying let those who
have ears to hear Let Them hear it but
we all know because it's just so
obviously repugnant that it is wrong for
two guys to create a kid in a test tube
to purchase a woman to to commodify
human beings to treat people as property
it's wrong to do that and we see that
and we we have that natural reaction
well perhaps we ought to apply some
reason then and and uh investigate why
it's wrong and how that might apply to
more people just than the the those who
are a little light in the loafers and
eager to have children uh without doing
the things properly necessary to have
children man what a great clip that was
now hey hey hey hey hold up you got to
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
nlls YouTube channel we'll see you next
time